frank wright the head coach of the colts
told albert breer of si.com
that uh
until they found out carson wentz was
going to be available
what they were doing was focusing on
drafting their future quarterback and
you know ballard himself said last year
late in the season that you don't just
draft a first round quarterback to draft
a first round quarterback i mean they
would have to feel good about their
options and because they were a playoff
team
they're down in that range where the
best are going to be gone unless they're
planning some move or would have been
planning some move up in the draft so uh
it's easy to say that now that they have
wentz i just don't know that they would
have definitely gotten someone that they
would have felt good about right but
they definitely feel good about wentz
you got jim irsay the owner of the team
all fired up and talking about a golden
era of colts football they've gone from
peyton manning to andrew luck and now
carson wentz and irsay always gets
excited about the possibilities they
only got one super bowl win over the
last 20 plus years though and uh you
know we'll see if carson wentz gets them
closer to one starting this year chris
yeah no i mean we'll see i mean yeah i
think chris ballard and frank wright
certainly would have been doing their
homework on trying to draft a
quarterback the next guy or whatever it
is but you're right where they were in
the first round it's going to be tough
they'd probably have to make a move or
hope somebody felt the second round and
then maybe they could trade up then do
something like that but
you know
this is this is a guy frank reich has
first-hand experience with
he loved him coming out of the draft of
course he was a big part of them
drafting him in philadelphia and he got
to see the makeup of the guy all
together let alone he got to see the guy
do some special things you know again i
know carson wentz it hasn't been perfect
it has not he's definitely had some of
his own issues but they have done him no
justice in the way they've played or set
up their team the last few years either
it didn't really fit carson wentz and it
didn't help that it didn't help
accentuate you know his strengths and
what he can do as a football player
i mean honestly the way their offense
was last year they were better off with
jalen hurts at the end of the year oh no
receivers we can't throw it let's get a
running quarterback move the pocket do
those type of things you know
quarterback design runs you know that
that honestly fit their team better but
whether you go back to 2019 and that end
of the game end of the season run they
had to get in the playoffs on nine and
seven i you you you have to be crazy to
not watch that and think oh man that was
special
it was a bunch of no names and carson
wentz
at quarterback he carried them into the
playoffs and then you know as we've said
many times we've seen him play at an mvp
caliber level
consistently through what was it 14
weeks of a year 13 weeks of a year that
year when they went to the super bowl so
you know that's where i think frank
reich buys in to to the carson wentz let
alone he knows his system
and his players are better than what
one's had in philadelphia and fit wins
better and i think that's where it has a
chance to be special
and that's exactly what reich told breer
looking at those games at the end of the
2019 season when the eagles were five
and seven they had to win out and he had
no help around him and he did now i
still would want to reconcile that with
what happened last year but as i've said
all along reich is in a unique position
where
he can talk to doug peterson and find
out what happened he can talk to carson
wentz and find out what happened and yes
their versions may be distinct you know
every sitcom that ever makes it past
five or six seasons seems to inevitably
have one of those episodes where
something happened and the first act is
one person's version the second act is
the other person's version and the third
act is exactly what happened it's for
right to figure out act three of exactly
what happened but he has access
to both of the guys who were on either
end of whatever triggered that
relationship to fall apart in
philadelphia so rank's smart enough to
to understand he's an old-timer pete
he's smart enough to figure out what
what uh what went on and how to make it
work going forward
well why is beyond his years as pete
would say that's uh from page 73 of the
sims
the other thing too mike i mean just you
know again
all you got to do is look at the stat
sheet from the the eagles last year
that's all that's the first thing you
can do is a basic fan and just go
wait who led the team in receptions and
you're oh wait who's this guy what that
guy did oh greg ward i mean greg ward
fulgam
dallas goddard who was hurt for you know
a period of the year
you know jalen rieger which was a bad
first round pick by the eagles to this
point i mean there's nothing there that
says oh man
he really left a lot out of there i mean
man that eagle's offense it should have
been top five but carson wentz messed it
up like bullcrap that often stunk i
don't know anyone to say that either did
carson once compounded by trying to do
too much and to try to like he tried too
hard to carry the football team i think
like he did in those last four weeks to
go to the playoffs in 2019 yeah i do i
think he fell a little bit into the trap
of like i'm gonna make magic happen i'm
gonna hold the ball forever i'm gonna
smash this ball into here and do a tight
window and it compounded itself but i
don't think it takes away from the
talent the guy still has
and you know i think frank wright sees
something within the human being too
that makes him that can make him
successful too
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports